eu me considero na verdade um grande
comunicador na verdade a a minha
descoberta né
no cosmos é a comunicação então seja o
uso essa grande competência que a
comunicação nos diversos ambientes onde
estou e eu descobri que essa essa
habilidade que construiu essa
competência é fundamental pra gente
desmistificar desmistificar várias
coisas então o meu grande talento muitas
vezes é trazer coisas que às vezes está
na cabeça de todo mundo mas não está
claro pra todo mundo e essa é a nossa
grande tarefa nessa tal que aqui sobre
isso já começa com a temática né
é essa tal de sustentabilidade porque
todos aqui estão têm condições de pegar
e dizer este ano já houve essa palavra
só que assim eu fico não não isso aí é é
não é pra mim não é pra mim não isso é
para uns malucos
isso é pra quem gosta isso eu não tenho
envolvimento com isso mas como algo
alguma palavra que é impossível qualquer
um dessa sala dizer que nunca ouviu não
faz parte de você
é impossível esse marketing de massa
chegar tão grande na cabeça das pessoas
e ela não fazer parte de você isso ser
simplesmente uma moda e é essa idéia é
que a gente vai tentar desmistificar
aqui um erro comum que a gente tende a
ouvir né das pessoas nas corporações
onde for é simbolizar sustentabilidade
com o verde começa a observar que todas
as expressões que vocês ouvem a empresa
desenvolve ações de sustentabilidade ela
faz coleta de resíduos ela faz
aproveitamento da água da chuva e ela
verde e ao verde e ao verde e nós somos
sustentáveis porque nós coletamos água
da chuva nós aproveitamos esse tona e
verde e verde e verde ou seja então não
estamos falando de sustentabilidade não
estamos falando em meio ambiente
mas se nós observarmos isso está quase
que um sinônimo na cabeça
das pessoas então primeira grande tarefa
gente ou se é e isso é igual porque tem
um novo conceito então ou seja algo está
errado
algo está errado eu deveria falar de
meio ambiente e não falar de
sustentabilidade se isso é sinônimo nós
estamos com dois conceitos que não tem
sentido
então vamos abrir um pouco mais sobre
isso desenvolvimento vamos pensar em
desenvolvimento e vocês vão começar a se
dar conta que agora sustentabilidade faz
a vida de vocês a lei entrou e vocês nem
perceberam porque no passado a gente
dizia que ó ser ter desenvolvimento a
gente precisa de emprego e renda a gente
precisa de emprego e renda se a gente
tem emprego e renda a gente é feliz
porque a gente tem emprego e renda a
gente consegue fazer as coisas a gente
tem dinheiro para fazer as coisas só que
agora a gente se deu conta se eu tenho
emprego e renda sem saúde isso não é tão
legal e eu opto por ficar em casa e não
trabalhar num lugar que me dá emprego e
renda mas também em nome da saúde
e eu posso ter dinheiro nossa estou com
dinheiro meu deus nós estamos com muito
dinheiro com muito dinheiro muito
dinheiro ea pior doença deste século com
todo mundo tendo maior dinheiro do mundo
a repressão mas não reconhece o sentido
da vida na herança passada que nós
tínhamos esse dinheiro pra gente tem
emprego e renda pra gente conseguir as
coisas e agora a gente já está com 100
saúde isso não tá tão legal e eu estou
deprimido com tudo que eu tenho isso
começa não ter sentido e também a gente
começa meu deus do céu sem água também
não tem sentido e agora a gente se dá
conta também que a gente não quer apenas
uma casa para morar porque ela também
não tem sentido se ela for estruturado
ela não cair
ela tem que ser bela como este palco do
tex
a gente tem que ter beleza cênica onde a
gente está a gente tem que sentir bem
a gente tem que conquistar com o olho a
gente não come mais com a boca a gente
come com o ouvido a gente come com um
olhar a gente come pelo sentido do
paladar também a gente precisa de um
belo prato também associado a isso e
vocês vão ler pra mim eu pode ser que
isso tem a ver com sustentabilidade
total porque agora a grande a outro povo
já esquecido como assim eu vou dizer que
algo está se desenvolvendo eu tô bem mas
eu vejo um mendigo na rua um morador de
rua morador de rua uma opção é diferente
mendigo né está lá e está sem opção ou
seja diferente
ou seja não posso achar que algo está se
desenvolvendo dentro de si macro né
e aí começa a fazer sentido
o desenvolvimento baseado em
sustentabilidade na cabeça de vocês isso
está na cabeça de vocês só que a gente
não percebe porque a gente hoje se dá
conta de que se dá conta que não há como
ter desenvolvimento sem esses três
elementos
precisamos não sejam contra o
desenvolvimento econômico nós precisamos
da economia para trocar os bens para que
se movimente os bens porque eu quero
comer um pão eu quero vestir uma blusa
eu quero isso necessita disso então a
economia faz bem também
só que a gente se deu conta que somente
trocar os bens sem um ambiente limpo se
estivesse suja esse palco se tivesse
essa sala sem um ar que a gente tivesse
convincente é impossível aprendizado bem
como se nós não tivéssemos aí o a
diferença e bota sociedade organização
social se nós não tivéssemos essa
organização eu não teria como falar em
vocês como ouvir porque estariam
tentando interagir comigo a todo momento
ea tal que também não ia acontecer
ou seja acabamos de promover neste
momento o desenvolvimento sustentável
nessa microcosmos que nós estamos aqui
ou seja isso não é uma moda está na
nossa necessidade de vida então ou seja
por isso que está na cabeça de todo
mundo e não sai mais
porque ele não é uma moda não vai passar
nós estamos nos dando conta que nós
necessitamos mesmo que inconscientemente
nós estamos os três elementos para ter
desenvolvimento ou que nós queremos
qualidade de vida pode ver que ninguém
mais quer é ser imortal não é uma luta
eu quero viver para sempre
eu quero não morrer não a gente quer ter
qualidade de vida posso até morrer cedo
mas com qualidade de vida
a gente já começou a inverter este fluxo
também por causa que o desenvolvimento
sustentável está vinculado nesses três
pilares ea gente conforme vai
desenvolvendo mais falar mas pra cá um
pouco de economia e preservando os
recursos eu sou mais ecoeficientes eu
tenho uma economia desenvolvendo a
sociedade eu sou mais socioeconômicos eu
tenho uma sociedade cuidando da questão
da preservação ambiental eu sou mais
sócio
ambiental ou seja roda fica girando e eu
conforme a necessidade deste
desenvolvimento eu vou trabalhando ela
isso então é um modelo de
desenvolvimento que no passado foi
baseado na economia a gente mede o
desenvolvimento por economia e hoje a
gente mesmo que ache que não
inconscientemente a gente consegue
entender que o desenvolvimento está
associado a um desenvolvimento
sustentável
usem como vocês quiserem eu sempre digo
mas entendam isso não querem chamar de
sustentabilidade querem chamar todo mas
entendam que é isso que move o
desenvolvimento desta nova era
e aí associado a isso olha como está na
cabeça das pessoas quando a gente fala
tenha um consumo consciente o consumo
consciente chamar quase mil ou a
expressão na sequência de pensar o
desenvolvimento sustentável só que o
novamente o grande erro pessoal olha
tenha consciência consumo consciente tem
eu tenho que ter eu tenho que ter um
consumo consciente a primeira coisa que
eu tenho que ter um consumo consciente
eu tenho que gastar menos e gastar menos
essa é porque eu eu gosto mais do que eu
ganho então tem que gastar menos então
isso o consumo consciente consumo
consciente aí eu tenho desperdiçar menos
o meio ambiente meio ambiente meio
ambiente diz pensar por que meio
ambiente porque o recurso ea gente
gastar menos porque têm menos recursos
só que a grande variável hoje
questionada é saber de onde vem
você sabe aonde está vendo que você está
consumindo ou de quem que vem será que
meu consumo está também desenvolvendo
uma economia local será que eu tô
favorecendo que meu amigo também se
desenvolva a partir do meu consumo e
muitas vezes não está associado somente
ao meio ambiente
mas eu consigo também minimizar o
impacto fazendo essa ação ou quantos de
nós em vez de ver um amigo abrindo um
novo empreendimento e ir no local para
incentivar porque ele está começando
porque qualquer um de nós sabe que não
tem como não tem como no início ele terá
a velocidade do atendimento que a gente
julga ser burra tem os todo mundo
capacitado da forma ideal para servir
aquela necessidade que eu tenho de
atendimento quem não sabe disso todos
sabem disso mas eu pego meu amigo abre e
eu tenho um sentimento que
em abril porque quer ficar rico quer
saber
vou lá pra ver chega lá não atende saiu
digo fecha em três meses e você acabou
de não favorecer o desenvolvimento de
forma ampla de forma ampla então seja a
gente está muito mais perto de trabalhar
o desenvolvimento sustentável do que nós
pensamos
o desafio dos 3r grande questão em
desenvolvimento se nós pegarmos a nossa
realidade hoje atual tô falando à
realidade brasileira eu coloque o
desenvolvimento social porque dentro dos
três pilares a gente nunca teve apesar
de nós temos uma situação econômica não
favorável tem gente que em 20 anos é
primeiro 30 anos é a primeira crise
pesada que sente se nós pegarmos no
passado pessoal já passei por várias
essa é mais uma etapa outros estavam
desespero total
então quero dizer que assim é querendo
ou não no que na crise que estamos ainda
economicamente têm maior capacidade de
trocar bens do que há 20 anos atrás
ambientalmente somos providos por
natureza o brasil nosso brasil querido
brasil é provido por natureza no rio
grande do sul é muito complicado no ano
passado de muita chuva muita muita chuva
muita chuva e vento falar assim a gente
vai faltar água é complicado debater
sobre este assunto no rio grande onde
choveu muito muito e ainda temos espaço
e ainda essas questões que são
realidades muitas vezes diferente em
outros aspectos mas nós temos essa
condição ambiental agora qual é a nossa
grande crise do desenvolvimento
sustentável em nosso país é
desenvolvimento social e não estou
falando apenas e é importante a
assistência mas é desenvolvimento de um
senso de sociedade senso de sociedade
essa nossa crise resolveu o meu tá tudo
certo ou seja não preciso mais me
preocupar
na verdade nós necessitamos aumentar o
nosso senso de sociedade nosso senso de
que eu chamo de princípio da
participação novamente quer
desmistificar um novo conceito que a
gente traz as pessoas estão participando
muitas vezes de repente
a gente pode usar o indicador nesta tal
que de que as pessoas estão participando
é apresentar a lista de chamada e dizer
às pessoas participaram
elas poderiam estar domingo dormindo
elas poderiam estar paradas poderiam
estar olhando seu celular e não
prestando atenção em nada mas eu uso
esse indicador de participação com a
lista de presença
isso não é sinônimo de participação a
melhor definição que eu achei é agir
pelo conjunto participar é quando você
age pelo conjunto novamente estamos
promovendo a sustentabilidade aqui pelo
princípio da participação onde o desafio
é o desafio do desenvolvimento social
onde a gente conseguiu criar um senso de
sociedade ac onde vocês estão quietos e
eu estou falando que a gente consegue
ter uma participação sem você se
movimentarem daí que nós geramos uma
participação uma interação porque nós
criamos esse senso de sociedade e aí um
outro ponto a bacanas algo muito legal
muito interessante mas com como faço
isso como eu faço as pessoas agirem pelo
conjunto desenvolver essa sociedade
informação e educação informação e
educação muita informação passamos dessa
fase já temos já temos já temos já temos
já temos já temos agora nós precisamos
educar mais e quer ver como a gente pode
sem esses elementos a gente não acha
pelo conjunto se eu perguntasse quem
aqui acredita que o esgoto tratar o
esgoto não é necessário não todos nós
meu deus escuta fundamental nós temos
que tratar o esgoto porque o esgoto
realmente o problema todo mundo vai
concluir isso só que todo mundo agora
concluir isso eu vou fazer você diz
concluir no momento que eu digo assim
você consegue daqui meu deus eu tenho
que tratar o esgoto eu tenho é realmente
trata o esgoto é muito importante só que
eu chego em casa saiu de casa de manhã
preparado pra ver para tal que voltar
para casa
quando você chega em casa voltou sua
roupa bonita estendida lá fora e você
está chegando em casa e olha uma valeta
um buraco aberto na frente da sua rua
com um monte de terra espalhada duas
máquinas ali e aí não entende o que está
acontecendo e você fica disse
a dupé da vida ea primeira coisa que
liga pra prefeito diz quem foi o animal
que fez estoque e eu quero e vou acionar
um advogado para impedir que isto
aconteça e depois de muito tempo quando
você já trancou a obra já trancou tudo
descobre que aquilo era canalização para
o seu esgoto na sua rua então você
acabou de não agir pelo conjunto
mas qual é que foi um erro não lhe
informaram que iria acontecer
agora se eu faço uma comunicação
anterior prezados moradores não
estaremos aqui nós estamos passando a
uma obra o ator informando a uma obra
que vai acontecer agora vou tocar uma
obra de saneamento para coletar o esgoto
na sua rua sabe que o esgoto acontece
não têm cinema aquele problema de cheiro
que acontece na água quando você tem no
verão pois é a captação e perto de
esgoto é mesmo a melhor do ano que
bacana que é interessante legal bacana o
que entende compreende tudo foi
informado e fui educado chegou o cara da
obra e oferece um café e abra logo este
buraco né
ou seja a partir de então eu começo a
agir pelo conjunto então nós temos que
melhorar nossa participação nós
precisamos informar nós precisamos
educar mais e pra finalizar então queria
fazer esse fechamento de entendimento
sobre este modelo de desenvolvimento que
o seguinte não há alguém ou não a
empresa ou não a que diga eu sou
sustentável e parei
ele não é o fim é um trajecto como se
diz em ética a cada momento a gente muda
as formas de se relacionar com as
pessoas então a gente pensar em um
manual travado de ética é impossível
da mesma maneira que nossas relações e
tecnologias relações humanas relações
econômicas relações ambientais com meio
mudam
ele é uma busca o que é importante que a
gente descobriu que é três elos que
fazem a gente dizer o que representar
qualidade de vida uma economia bem
desenvolvida associada com o
desenvolvimento de uma sociedade em um
ambiente preservado
esqueçam este sinônimo dizer que
proteger o meio ambiente é sustentável
tadeu não proteger o meio ambiente de
fato faz parte integra sustentabilidade
só que somente meio ambiente não é estar
trabalhando em prol do desenvolvimento
sustentável e nosso desafio de fato é
desenvolver essa sociedade
ser cidadão ser participativo a ação
pelo conjunto e tirar mais a força
interna nossa para a resolução de
problemas
essa é a mensagem que eu queria passar
para vocês e meu muito obrigado